formule par internet qui font qu'il ya
une fuite fiscale considérable si on
continue comme ça sans se préoccuper des
recettes et bien nous conduirons
toujours nos retraités d'ailleurs pas
seulement nos retraités notre sécurité
sociale notre pays un malthusianisme
c'est à dire qu'on se préoccupe de
réduire les dépenses
au lieu d'augmenter les recettes et de
les mettre au service de l'ensemble des
retraités qui ont travaillé dur dans
notre pays pour construire la france
d'aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le député monsieur
rapporta merci monsieur le président
monsieur le député dupont aignan nous
partageons cet objectif de justice
fiscale
nous partageons surtout le fait qu' il
nous semble qu'il faut le garantir pour
l'avenir et le garantir pour l'avenir
compte tenu des évolutions
démographiques c'est de mutualiser
l'ensemble des actifs pour que
l'ensemble des actifs puissent assumer
l'ensemble des pensions avec des règles
communes parce que la retraite est un
dans un temps particulier où il nous
semble que l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
doivent pouvoir partir dans des
conditions équitables et équivalente
et donc c'est en ça que nous nous
pensons que notre notre projet est juste
mais défavorables à votre proposition
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président sur cet amendement de monsieur
débuté dupont aignan qui fait référence
à la justice fiscale c'est un concept
qui pour moi n'a pas grand chose à faire
avec les principes sociaux qui font
notre système c'est que le député donc
l'avis du gouvernement est défavorable
merci monsieur mise madame madame ôta
alors nous avons deux réponses qui sont
pas tout à fait les mêmes
monsieur pourquoi nous dit que bien sûr
le gouvernement et la majorité en marche
est attaché à la justice fiscale ce qui
sera une belle nouvelle si nous n'étions
pas là à nouveau dans un exercice de
novlangue parce que quand un
gouvernement une majorité a permis aux
plus riches d'échappée l isf a instauré
la flat tax l'idée de justice sociale
est quand même assez étrangement
apprécié et si le ministre nous dit que
la justice fiscale n'a strictement rien
à voir avec ce texte
dans ce cas là j'aurais au moins une
question on sait pas si c'est les jouit
la justice sans doute plus que la
fiscalité parfois j'aurais au moins une
question c'est que les exonérations
fiscales qui ont été faites aux
entreprises et qui donne un manque à
gagner dans les caisses de retraite ça
ça quand même un petit peu à voir et on
sait qu'aujourd'hui ce sont 5 milliards
d'euros en moins dans les caisses de
retraite parce que l'état n'a pas
compensé l'effet des exonérations
fiscales que votre gouvernement a décidé
de faire don cas quand même un petit
lien entre les deux et à quand même un
petit lien entre les deux donc il
faudrait s'entendre
est ce que vous n'avez décidément rien à
faire de l'injustice fiscale ou est ce
que vous essayez de nous expliquer que
ça n'aurait rien à voir alors que pour
le coup il y a bien un lien entre les
deux merci monsieur valeo oui je crois
qu'il faut prendre la formule de justice
fiscale sans injustice fiscale au social
c'est-à-dire poser aussi la question de
la justice des cotisations or on a vu
par exemple que toutes les cotisations
ne produisait pas les mêmes droits
qu'eux et on est bien des cas dans
lequel un euro cotisé ne produisent pas
les mêmes droits
on a vu pour les générations nées avant
75 qui vont cotiser son secret de droits
supplémentaires à la retraite
on l'a vu pour par exemple les retraités
avant l'âge des équilibres qui
cumulerait un emploi qui cotiseront sans
se créer de droit on a bien bien bien
bien des exemples et puis évidemment à
travers
7cette cet amendement on peut poser la
question au gouvernement de savoir ce
qu'il va advenir de la politique
d'exonération de cotisations sociales
dans le nouveau régime
et ce quelles pourraient en être les
prolongements par exemple il est vrai
que l'alignement de tous les régiments
parti de kiel et les régimes publics
avec le régime privé peut poser la
question de savoir si à un moment donné
un employeur public surtout après la
réforme que vous avez conduite j'allais
dire avilissant le statut de la fonction
publique
s'ils ne seront pas au nom du principe
d'égalité fondé à demander les mêmes
politique d'exonération est là que l'on
voit que leur répondez vous merci je
mets au voile l'amendement de monsieur
dupont aignan le 37 cents à 112 avis
défavorable du gouvernement et de la
commission qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est repoussé nous en venons à des
amendements identiques
le 360 disent allez-y me / vannier
oui amendement de notre collègue et zèle
il est promu primordial pardon de figer
les droits qu'ils méritent les personnes
qui ont travaillé toute leur vie pour
avoir une retraite convenable
en effet les augmentations de
prélèvements obligatoires l'instabilité
fiscale l'augmentation du coût de la vie
non contrebalancée par une baisse de
charges sur les retraites font que la
situation économique et financière et
plus qu'inconfortable
nous souhaitons donc inscrire dans la
loi qu'un minimum de pension de retraite
ne peut être diminuée merci le 24 635
mal à ménard
merci monsieur le président oui comme
vient de le défendre mon collègue alain
ramadi l'instabilité fiscale et les
augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires pèse évidemment sur les
pensions de retraite et donc dé facto
sur le niveau de vie de nos retraités
cela les place parfois dans une
situation de précarité économique et
financière comme nous avons pu le
constater lorsque votre majorité avait
décidé d'augmenter la csg sur les
retraités aisés
c'est à dire ce qui touchait à l'époque
plus de 1200 euros par mois c'est pour
pallier ce genre de déconvenue qui
engendre de réel des difficultés
financières pour nos retraités qu'il
convient d'inscrire me semble t'il dans
la loi que le premier versement de
pensions de retraite ne pourra plus
ultérieurement faire l'objet d'une
baisse d'une diminution et cela quelles
que soient les circonstances économiques
et les changements de politique fiscale
je vous remercie monsieur le président
merci madame ménard monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président
l'ensemble des règles et paramétrer
modalités de pilotage des droits à la
retraite trouvent leur place dans les
articles suivants notamment l'article 9
qui fixe les modalités d'indexation et
valeur d'acquisition et de service du
point l'article 11 qui fixe les règles
de revalorisation des pensions versées
et pour répondre précisément
sous-amendement de madame ménard
l'article 55 qui précise que le montant
des retraites ne peut pas ne peut pas
baisser et ça a été indiqué de façon
plus gravé dans le marbre dans l'article
1 de la loi organique donc défavorable à
ces amendements car pour certains ils
ont ils seront traités plus tard et puis
dans l'esprit ils sont ils sont
satisfaits donc des falloir alors
monsieur le ministre et après me
seigneurie on n'essaiera de corriger
quelque chose monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président comme le
rapporteur l'a indiqué ces amendements
sous-amendement envoie des dispositions
sont prévues à l'alinéa 22 de l'article
55 également à l'article plonge
j'ai un avis défavorable monsieur le
président merci monsieur minery je
n'avais pas le sous-amendement 42 380
gelé désormais vous avez déposé un
sous-amendement de ce signal il faudrait
que le présenter merci merci monsieur
présent oui c'est un mouvement de
précisions rien ne pouvait justifier
qu'une pension de retraite des
meilleures raisons de des circonstances
économiques ou de changement de la
politique fiscale et c'est pour ça qu'à
la première phase de la linea 2 après le
mot peuvent je voulais insérés les mots
en aucun cas monsieur le monsieur
rapportant vous maintenez un avis
défavorable sur monsieur le ministre
également
alors oui mme deux minutes deux minutes
alors sur ces amendements et sur ces
deux amendements et sur ces
sous-amendements il y avait monsieur
viry d'abord tu avais demandé la parole
oui merci monsieur faisons moi j'entends
là la position de monsieur le rapporteur
est le monsieur le ministre vous savez
on a eu un précédent
on a vu un précédent dans cette
législature en matière de pensions de
retraite avec une décision votre
décision avec un choix politique de
désindexer les pensions moi je considère
que à cet article 1er l'article socle de
votre projet de loi il convient de poser
désormais qu'on ne touchera plus aux
pensions des retraités de france c'est
la raison pour laquelle moi je comprends
la pensée de nos collègues et zèle et
c'est un moment ils méritent me
semble-t-il d'être transcrire dans cet
article 1er on ne peut pas attendre un
article successives pour rappeler cette
règle parce qu on a été échaudés par
votre décision
et parce que motivé votre refus par
l'article 1er d'une loi organique
d'hôtes on peine à croire qu eu égard au
déroulé de nos travaux on puisse
commencer à esquisser le débat ne paraît
pas raisonnable
donc moi je considère que cet amendement
il est juste
pertinents et ils sauvegardent
réellement le niveau de vie des
retraités dernier mot monsieur le
président on a terminé la séance tout à
l'heure sur une question essentielle sur
globalement les conséquences de nos
débats qui s'allonge avec cette question
et j'en ai pour 20 secondes cette
question du coût éventuel de nos débats
moi je considère ce débat totalement
scandaleux cette assemblée a déjà
travaillé les week-ends dans cette
législature
dès le début en juillet 2017 pourra
dernier pour un texte pardon sur la
moralisation de la vie publique
sanaa chagriné personnes à ce moment là
qu'on travaille les week-ends sur un
texte comme le système des retraites
qu'on doit travailler le samedi et le
dimanche ça ne doit choquer aucun
français et il faut savoir donner du
temps sur six textes comme ça donc de
grâce pas de polémique
pas de polémique sur le fait qu'on
puisse éventuellement travailler le
samedi et dimanche et que
potentiellement ça puisse coûter
quelques euros la démocratie elle a pas
de prix et jamais on devra savez c'est
un mal compris madame autun on va
essayer les uns et les autres de rester
dans dans les deux minutes
oui merci si j'ai bien lu les
amendements proposés par nos collègues
sur les bancs de l'opposition de droite
s'agit de revenir à une indexation sur
fin bien de revenir mais de maintenir
une indexation sur sur l'inflation
donc je voulais dire que pour notre part
on défend des une indexation sur les
salaires et non pas sur l'inflation
sachant que depuis ces décennies qu'on a
basculé de l'un sur l'autre c'est une
baisse qui a été constatée du niveau des
pensions et donc j'interroge à nouveau
le ministre propose de cette occasion
puisque là vous avez trouvé un troisième
blessé on est pas dans les revenus on
n'est pas dans l'inflation
on est dans le revenu d'activité par
tête
je voulais savoir si par rapport à ce
moment de la commission vous a beaucoup
interrogé sur ce sujet que vous nous
avez donc renvoyé
un indice qui pourrait être effectuée
par l'insee que lindsey dis donc il n'a
pas envie de le faire est ce que vous
pouvez aujourd'hui être un peu plus
précis pour nous dire ce qu'est ce
revenu d'activité de base qui fera
partie des paramètres qui permettront
d'évaluer le point la valeur du point
ainsi beaucoup madame auteur madame du
monde merci monsieur le président
revenir d'un beau quand même sur la
réponse du rapporteur qui était un petit
peu toujours la même et là c'est soit
les amendements viennent trop tôt soit
ils sont satisfaits parce qu'on verra
plus tard pour moi je vous le dis à
l'instar de ce que vient de dire notre
collègue des républicains d'ailleurs
mais l'article 1 il définit bien les
objectifs dont qu'il n'épuise pas le
sujet mais il est absolument essentiel
c'est d'ailleurs pas par hasard si c'est
l'article 1 sur un texte qui en comptent
donc on peut pas renvoyer à plus tard
les réponses au fond d'ailleurs le plus
tard on en est même pas sûr puisque
plane toujours au dessus de cet
hémicycle cette histoire de 49,3 ou pas
d'ailleurs la question c'est pas tant
l'utilisation ou pas du 49-3 c'est
plutôt que d'abord ce serait un scandale
démocratique
évidemment mais nous ce qu'on redoute le
plus c'est pas le 49-3 ce sont les
conséquences de cette réforme et c'est
pour ça qu'on veut être éclairé et on ne
l'est pas donc on ne veut pas voter sur
des objectifs qui sont dans l'article 1
la solidarité la lisibilité l'équité et
c'est qu'ils seraient démenti contredit
par les articles suivants quand bien
même cela viendrait à l'article 40 50
donc on pose des questions et on veut
être éclairée que vous éclairer la
représentation nationale au moment où
les questions sont posées
merci monsieur dupont-aignan
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
quand je lis dans cet article mais un
objectif de garantie d'un niveau de vie
satisfaisant retraité de versement d'une
retraite en rapport avec les revenus
perçus pendant la vie active
c'est une déclaration d'amour et quand
je lis l'amendement je vois une preuve
d'amour et je préfère les preuves
d'amour aux déclarations donc je pense
que il y aurait besoin d'affirmer une
garantie parce que
les français ont vu votre politique et
ont vu la désindexation ont vu la csg
ont vu cette façon d'entamer le pouvoir
d'achat donc c'est curieux d'ailleurs
que si vous saviez vous satisfaire
génial tellement de ce projet que vous
seriez pas capable d'écrire dans les
premiers articles quelques éléments qui
seraient de nature à rassurer nos
concitoyens
cc je ne vois en aucun je ne vois pas en
quoi vous pourriez refusé de voter cet
amendement bon alors vous le refusez ça
prouve bien que ce ne sont que des mots
paroles paroles comme disait la chanson
merci madame ménard
merci monsieur le président oui je me
permets d'insister sur cet amendement
puisque comme l'a rappelé mon collègue
viry a eu un précédent quand même une
attaque en règle contre nos retraités
vous avez déjà vous avez cette majorité
a déjà des indexées les pensions de nos
retraités et c'était il ya un an il y
avait deux populations visées à ce
moment là les retraités et les familles
et je vous rappelle que vous avez
vous-même finalement fait votre mea
culpa fait marche arrière
d'une part en revenons sur sur cette non
indexé sur sur 7 sur 7 ha d inflation en
fait des indexations pardon sur
l'inflation puisque vous êtes rendu
compte que c'était une bêtise mais enfin
vous avez dû vous en rendre compte après
un mouvement social de gilet jaune qui a
duré quand même de nombreux mois oui mea
culpa partiel effectivement comme vous
le dites
et puis et d'autre part sur le montant
de cette cg qui touchait les retraités
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure les
retraités selon vous aisée je vous
rappelle que c'était ceux au départ qui
touchait 1200 euros par mois pour vous
c'est aider votre été aisée et vous êtes
revenu vous avez votre mea culpa en
remontant le seuil d'indexation de 2,2
d'imposition de la csg aux retraités qui
touchait 2000 euros par mois
donc vous avez touché deux fois deux
fois nous retraités au porte monnaie
donc je pense que l'erreur est humaine
certes mais autant figer les choses dans
la loi et pour rassurer complètement nos
retraités qui le méritent
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas que c'est
pas un cadeau qu'on leur fait un
ils ont travaillé toute leur vie pour ça
donc autant de figer et le marquer dans
la loi pour que les choses soient très
claires vis-à-vis de nos retraités je
vous remercie monsieur le président
merci madame ménard madame de la bière
merci monsieur le président j'écoute les
orateurs des différents groupes et non
inscrits et je constate que nous avons
une préoccupation commune
nous aimerions débattre du fond et vous
avez l'air inquiète notamment chers
collègues que nous ne puissions pas le
faire
vos articles que vous avez cités dans
lequel nous parlerions effectivement du
point de son indexation de comment les
pensions seraient revalorisés pour
donner des vraies garanties aux français
sur la base d'un débat de fonds
équilibrés et donc il m'est venu une
idée une idée toute simple qui pourrait
peut-être de retirer quelque chose comme
31 mille amendements identiques que nous
avons sur ce texte soit vous obstruée et
vous assumer le fait que ça n'est pas
possible d'avoir un débat organisé sur
le fond soit vous cesser cette
obstruction et nous avançons
merci je me mets aux voix ah oui mais
non mais il faut le demander monsieur
dharréville à je vous ai pas vus le
caylar et ville vous avez la parole
monsieur vallot ne l'a pas parce que le
groupe socialiste s'est déjà exprimée
monsieur vélo bien monsieur le président
je veux pas rentrer dans une discussion
avec nos collègues sur sur le thème qui
vient d'être évoqué je préfère parler du
texte est donc ici il s'agit d'un
amendement qui me permet au moins de
signaler que
évidemment eux
la question de fall et les pensions
contrairement à ce qui a été affichée
parfois de manière assez approximative
par un certain nombre de membres de la
majorité
eh bien elles sont indexées sur
l'inflation dans votre texte
et non pas sur les salaires c'était
quelque chose qui a parfois circulé de
manière assez approximative
c'est c'est pas ça qui est un accès sont
pas les pensions qui sont indexées sur
sur les salaires elles sont bien indexé
sur l'inflation donc ça c'est un premier
problème
la deuxième chose c'est qu'effectivement
à chaque fois que vous avez eu à voter
un budget vous les avez des index et
c'est ça la réalité des prix et donc
vous avez fait passer
l'augmentation des pensions en dessous
de l'augmentation du coût de la vie
voilà la politique que vous avez mené
donc ça mérite d'être rappelée dans
cette enceinte au moment où n'évoquons
cet amendement moi je comprend très bien
pourquoi ils étaient déposés par notre
collègue stéphane méry qui effectue on
veut se prémunir contre cette tentation
qui a été la vôtre de désindexer les
pensions alors que elles n'auraient pas
dû l'être
bon cela étant pour ce qui nous concerne
nous nous sommes favorables à
l'indexation des pensions sur les
salaires et donc ne souscrivons pas à
cette idée là nous comprenons l'idée de
cet amendement qui est amendement de
filets de sécurité un amendement de
repli d'une certaine façon mais l'idée
que nous portons nous c'est que les
pensions doivent être un accès sur les
salaires merci monsieur dans les villes
alors je mets aux voix les amendements
identiques on va commencer par le
sous-amendement de monsieur cinieri le
cas en de 380 sur lequel monsieur le
rapporteur et monsieur ministres ont
exprimé un avis défavorable qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est rejeté je me vois maintenant les
amendements identiques 370 est ce une
mêlée ménard le 24 635 qui est pour et
qui est contre
ils sont rejetés le 1649 monsieur
maisonnée
oui merci monsieur le président chers
collègues tout d'abord permettez moi de
vous dire un préambule l'honneur que
j'ai de m'exprimer pour la première fois
dans cet hémicycle et ce après sept mois
d'attentes à un moment que je crois
fondamental pour l'avenir des français
et du modèle social de ce pays
cet amendement est l'occasion de
rappeler le fonctionnement du modèle de
retraite par répartition auquel nous
sommes particulièrement attachés
vous le savez et auquel votre réforme
promet de faire énormément de mal le
système par répartition repose sur le
fait que les travailleurs actuels les
cotisants paye les pensions de retraites
des retraités actuels
cela implique donc deux choses 1
il faut que les actifs soient
suffisamment nombreux et 2
il faut qu'ils aient du travail cela je
crois n'a échappé à personne
d'où les deux piliers natalité et
emplois que nous proposons de rappeler
est d'inscrire dans cet article qui
décrit les principes généraux du ch'ti
du système de retraite universel
sur ces deux points d'ailleurs on ne
peut pas vraiment dire qu'il s'agisse de
priorité des politiques gouvernementales
sur merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président ben je salue
notre nouveau collègue même si je ne
partage pas les politiques portées par
votre mouvement je vous salue je vous
salue je sais je salue je salue votre je
salue or votre prise de parole monsieur
rapporteur s'exprimer je salue je salue
votre prise de parole et j'espère que
nous aurons l'occasion de débattre sur
sur le fond et en l'occurrence
vous avez rappelé le choix votre
attachement au choix d'un modèle par
répartition et nous aussi ce que je
pourrais permettre comme commentaire par
rapport à votre objectif c'est qu'on
donne beaucoup d'objectifs à au système
de retraite et qui est avant tout de
servir avant tout servir des retraites à
nos concitoyens pour autant évidemment
que nous sommes favorables à des
politiques de l'emploi à ce qui dit
politique de l'emploi dit d'abord
meilleure intégration des uns des autres
dit aussi par le travail plus de
cotisations et donc qui permet de facto
de servir de meilleures retraites et sur
la natalité il ya un certain nombre de
deux mesures en faveur de la famille
nous y reviendrons qui sont intégrés
dans dans ce projet nous aurons
l'occasion d'en débattre
donc défavorable à votre moment monsieur
le ministre
ainsi monsieur le président monsieur le
député je crois que votre amendement sur
le fond inverse l'ordre des facteurs qui
s'ignoraient les objectifs en matière
d'emploi et de natalité au système de
retraite vous savez il ya des politiques
publiques qui sont mises en oeuvre pour
cela et en matière d'emploi il ne vous a
pas échappé que notre pays venait de
passer en france métropole sous la barre
des 8% suite à l'action du gouvernement
défavorable merci alors madame ôta je
suis très étonné la réponse du
gouvernement et du rapporteur
je sais pas si tout le monde a bien lu
cet amendement qui est donc proposée par
notre nouveau collègue mais qui prend la
suite de monsieur collard et donc par
marine le pen il s'agit donc de mettre
dans les grands objectifs de la loi le
choix d'un financement par répartition
implique la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique favorable à l'emploi ça jusque
là tout le monde suit mais ensuite à la
natalité
alors tant que vous y êtes c'est vrai
qu'on aurait pu mettre aussi à
l'immigration peut être c'est favorable
également mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que là vous êtes en train d'introduire
dans les grands principes de notre
système
une visée natalistes alors je vous
reconnais la cohérence de vos positions
on n'a pas beaucoup entendu le son de
votre voix alors en commission quasiment
pas et monsieur chenu qui est venu 2
ici dans l'hémicycle et pour la première
fois que je l'entends et pour la fin
c'est pour avancer un objectif nataliste
dans les grands principes d'une loi sur
les retraites
pardonnez moi mais nous sommes au 21ème
siècle monsieur merci monsieur viry moi
je voudrais bien sûr cet amendement est
dérangeant mais il pose néanmoins un
vrai sujet dès lors que nous souhaitons
une un système de retraite par
répartition fondée sur une solidarité
intergénérationnelle
il faut une démographie soutenu et il
faut donc des enfants pour financer à
terme le système est forcément dans un
projet de réforme des retraites il faut
des droits familiaux et c'est une
véritable question est là encore
aujourd'hui un mot parce que je crains
qu'on ne puisse pas évoqué le sujet
lorsque l'article viendra et je sais que
cette préoccupation d'une politique
familiale peut être avisé nataliste
peut-être avisé natalistes il n'y a pas
que ça est partagée sur d'autres groupes
il y actuellement une mission
d'information sur les défis de la
politique de la famille en france
eu égard aux enjeux du 21e siècle c'est
un vrai sujet et 7 avril sujet qui
télescope la question des retraites
on ne peut pas effectivement plaidé
défendre un système par répartition sur
se soucier des réponses concrètes que
l'on accordera on considère monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur que le
gouvernement dans sa réponse est
défaillant on considère qu'en terme de
femme de mère de pension de reversions
vous êtes à côté de la plaque
il n'en demeure pas moins que notre
collègue avait le droit de déposer cet
amendement et puis un dernier mot
monsieur rapporteur vous avez là encore
commis une maladresse
une maladresse de langage notre collègue
il a été élu par le peuple
il est issu du suffrage universel et on
n'a pas le droit on n'a pas le droit de
caricaturer à une femme ou un homme qui
porte la fonction de député
selon ses opinions politiques
c'est un député dans toute sa nature
donc vous avez été effectivement me
semble-t-il
là encore maladroit je le déplore a et
merci monsieur ferry monsieur
dupont-aignan
oui c'est curieux tout le monde parle de
répartition or les deux conditions du
bon fonctionnement d'un système par
répartition c'est d'abord d'avoir une
natalité forte pour équilibrer notre
démographie et c'est ce que nous envient
l'italie l'espagne l'allemagne et c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs il est complètement
absurde de suivre les modèles de ces
pays car on nous dit toujours
l'allemagne l'allemagne mais si
l'allemagne a réduit la pension de ses
retraités c'est parce que son système
démographique ne permet pas le
renouvellement des générations et nous
avons la chance dans notre pays parce
que nous avons une politique familiale
qui a été d'ailleurs amende est réduite
au cours des deux derniers quinquennat
nous avons la chance d'avoir une
démographie forte qui nous permet de
fonctionner malheureusement nous n'avons
pas les emplois cas l'allemagne et tout
l'enjeu justement ce serait d'avoir une
vraie politique de relocalisation
d'emplois de protectionnisme intelligent
pour que nous rapatrions le million
d'emplois qui manquent et qui
équilibrerait tous nos systèmes sociaux
et éviterait la réduction permanente des
budgets sociaux qui font souffrir les
français donc bien évidemment la
répartition marche sur deux jambes une
politique de relocalisation d'emplois et
une politique nataliste forte
merci madame ménard oui merci monsieur
le président d'abord je voudrais quand
même dire dans cet hémicycle que
politique nataliste c'est pas un gros
mot
c'est pas honteux c'est pas parce qu'on
est au 21ème siècle qu'on peut pas avoir
une politique nataliste bien au
contraire faudrait m'expliquer pourquoi
on pourrait pas l'avoir
et puis j'ai bien écouté les réponses de
monsieur le rapporteur de monsieur le
ministre
moi j'ai pas vu quoi que ce soit sur les
droits familiaux dans votre texte
je vous rappelle et gelé déjà rappelé
tout à l'heure que l'année dernière
quand vous avez des indexées un certain
nombre de pensions notamment les
pensions de retraite c'est pour ça que
j'en parlais tout à l'heure les pensions
de retraite soit sur l'inflation vous
avez aussi d indexer les allocations
familiales
vous avez visé
deux sortes de populations les retraités
et les familles donc il me semble qu'on
peut être très occupée à juste titre
effectivement de votre politique envers
les familles et puis pour finir j'aurais
quand même aimé un autre accueil pour
notre collègue qui prend la première qui
prend pour la première fois la parole
dans cet hémicycle et je trouve
sincèrement en dehors de toute position
politique que franchement pour vous qui
vous déclarez et vous en fait des tonnes
sur ce domaine là que vous êtes tolérant
humanis tout ce que vous voulez
franchement c'était pas très chaleureux
et ça ne fait que reprendre un terme qui
a été déjà expliqué dans l'hémicycle
j'ai un peu honte de vous tous merci
merci madame ménard monsieur
villefranque
vous allez avoir monsieur val où la
parole mais après merci monsieur le
prion
c'est un moment à au moins le mérite
d'avoir posé à nouveau la question de
l'emploi
et si je dis cela à ce propos c'est
qu'ils s'adressent aussi à l'état
employeur et en la matière lorsqu'on
regarde comment les services publics
depuis des années et pour des années
encore notamment dans le cadre de votre
politique 4,22 prévoit de réduire
considérablement l'emploi de l'ordre de
10 mille postes dans les services
publics
tout cela va peser considérablement sur
bien évidemment les cotisations aux
régimes de sécurité sociale et donc sur
les déséquilibres qui sont engendrées à
titre d'exemple pas bien la cnr à celle
qui avait eu 10 100 millions de déficit
en 2010 8 prévoit un déficit de 4,5
milliards à échéance 2025
voilà le résultat d'une trajectoire de
réduction de l'emploi public sur lequel
vous en tant qu'employeur puisque l'état
en employeur vous avez tout votre
responsabilité
un haut niveau deux du déficit argumenté
de votre part sur le système merci
monsieur monsieur vélo oui je veux dire
bon on évoque la politique de l'emploi
évidemment elle a de l'importance et
derry la politique de l'emploi et la
politique salariale le partage de la
valeur ajoutée et un niveau de
cotisation qui permet de répondre à un
des curseurs de l'equilibre notre
système de retraite il ya sans doute l'
équilibre démographique avec les
naissances mais aussi le solde
migratoire
si nous devons tout évoquée comme
solution pose de nous la question de
savoir si nous avons un solde migratoire
suffisamment important pour répondre à
une partie du défi du déficit
démographique voilà moi je crois que on
peut tous cabrerisse concerne je suis
prêt à ce débat et à soutenir que ça
peut être utile
merci monsieur vélo alors je mets au
voile amendement de monsieur maisonnée
le 1649 avis défavorable de monsieur le
ministre et de monsieur le rapporteur
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté madame auconie le 9657
s'il vous plaît merci monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre je défends ici
l'amendement du président du groupe u10
agir indépendant jean christophe lagarde
qui participe 1 qui propose d'insérer
dans les principes de l'article 1er
l'idée finalement d'un outil financier
par la création d'un système mixte qui
combine qui combinerait en fait la
répartition et la capitalisation
finalement public
il s'agirait d'un système de retraite
universel par répartition qui ne serait
pas en opposition avec la création
éventuelle et
dans un futur plus ou moins proche d'un
système mixte associant une part de
capitalisation obligatoire à la
répartition je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur merci
monsieur le président non notre projet
de loi fait un choix clair sans
ambiguïté dans la rédaction dans nos
intentions défini un périmètre de
régimes de retraite obligatoire par
répartition après rien n'empêche ceux
qui veulent mettre en place de la
capitalisation de le faire mais la
définition du système de retraite
universel de systèmes de retraite
universel est un système par répartition
et je dirais encore plus large que ce
qu'il était au préalable en intégrant
les systèmes de retraites
complémentaires qui existait jusqu'à
présent
monsieur le ministre y fabrique
ainsi monsieur le président sur cet
amendement
madame la députée que vous portez haut
au nom aussi de votre président de
groupe
j'ai déjà apportées presque une réponse
cet après-midi en vous disant que vous
l'avez entendu je le vois à votre visage
en disant que notre système battait en
brèche celui que nous proposons au
système universel de retraite battre en
brèche
l'ouverture à la capitalisation
non pas parce qu'il est tabou de parler
de capitalisation je crois que le député
stéphane bierry s'est exprimée déjà sur
ce sujet là et on peut tout à fait
entendre moi même j'ai expliqué qu'il
existait déjà des dispositifs de
capitalisation d'ailleurs également dans
le public qu'on n'est pas dans un tabou
il ya eu de nombreuses reprises des
interventions qui ont à mon avis
confondues les dispositifs d'assurance
vie lé dispositif de retraite par
capitalisation qui sont quand même très
différent
rappelant aussi que le poids de ces
dispositifs
aujourd'hui capitalisation représente
moins de 2% de du poids des retraites
servies bon voila j'ai un avis
défavorable pour pour tout cela
madame la députée et en même temps
j'entends que la proposition qui était
faite ne visez pas à générer une tension
particulière ni dans le pays il y en a
ici que tout jeu je comprends bien la
lecture qui est fait qu'ils ont fait de
prendre acte de ce qui existe et en même
temps vous vous comprenez que le fait
que je veux absolument que le message
soit clair sur la répartition de notre
volonté d'inscrire cette répartition
dans l'adn de notre système de retraite
merci monsieur le ministre
alors nous engageons la discussion
madame autun oui merci d'abord un mot
pour emmanuel ménard qui demandait quel
était le problème
au 21ème siècle d'inscrire politique
nataliste donc je réponds de mon point
de vue bien sûr c'est tout simplement
que les politiques natalistes viste à
inciter les femmes à faire des enfants
et qu'il se trouve qu'au xxème siècle il
ya eu ce qu'on appelle une révolution
féministe c'est à dire une révolution
qui plaide pour l'émancipation des
femmes et le libre choix
le libre choix devant la maternité et
donc une politique familiale est une
chose une politique nataliste en est une
autre
c'est une politique qui incite les
femmes à faire des enfants est en effet
je pense que après la révolution
féministe il n'est plus possible
d'imaginer ce type de politiques
publiques
je reviens sur la question de cet
amendement qui a le mérite de poser la
question en des termes très simple c'est
que au fond votre loi elle va favoriser
le système par capitalisation
alors vous nous dites que vous
n'acceptez pas cet amendement parce
qu'il enverrait un message qui serait de
notre point de vue un message en réalité
de clarification de clarification parce
que quand vous excluez par exemple
toutes celles et ceux qui ont plus de
trois passes c'est à dire qu'ils gagnent
plus de 10000 euros par mois qu'est ce
que vous croyez qu'ils vont faire ils
sont plafonnés à 2 8% mais non 120000
euros et elle soit il est un peu si
emilie précieux petit break tout loisir
vous exprimer si vous en faites la
demande pour le moment c'est madame
moteur et alfio news je vous remercie
c'est souvent quand on touche à quelques
petits points sensibles en 16 ans
plombier dépannons plumejeau plaisir ça
fait toujours plaisir de vous réveiller
en tout cas il est absolument clair
qu'une partie va devoir compléter une
partie va devoir compléter par de la
capitalisation
voilà c'est ça qui va se passer et que
comme les pensions vont baisser
et bien c'est évident que et on l'a vu
d'ailleurs puisqu'elle est publicité de
fonds de pension qui a qui ont déjà
commencé à fleurir
il est bien évident que votre système va
favoriser parallèlement la
capitalisation alors que vous ne vouliez
pas l'écrire noir sur blanc parce que
c'est ce qu'on n'arrête pas de vous dire
est que vous expliquez nous expliquer
que pas du tout vous êtes dans un
système par répartition je le comprends
mais là aussi on est vraiment dans un
faux semblant
merci madame et l'image oui donc
monsieur monsieur beauty c'est madame
est l'image que s'expriment ah non mais
j'avais pas vu merci monsieur le
président à notre collègue je ne
partagerais certainement pas vos idées
de manière générale mais je vous
souhaite la bienvenue
un mot quand même très vite sur
la natalité parce que c'est quand même
un pays un problème dans ce pays que
cette natalité qui est bien bien trop
faible et qui évidemment un impact
direct sur le sujet sur lequel nous
travaillons aujourd'hui donc je crois
qu'il faut simplement et sereinement se
poser la question sans attente et
d'ailleurs je suis une femme et pour moi
y'a aucun problème à parler de natalité
et sa n'obère en rien ma liberté sur le
l'amendement en question je voudrais
qu'on revienne de minutes sur les mots
ce choix ne fait pas obstacle à la
création d'un système mixte combinant
répartition et capitalisation alors dans
le système actuel bien évidemment on le
trouve ces mécanismes existent de
capitalisation tant dans le public que
dans le privé avec préfon ou encore
agirc arrco toutefois je crois qu'il
faut rappeler l'essence véritablement à
la lettre de ce texte
nous réaffirmons et nous voulons
réaffirmant réaffirmer ici le principe
d'un système par répartition qui
s'appliquera à 99 % des assurés à 96%
d'être des revenus nous ne pouvons
évidemment pas soutenir un tel
amendement mais nous voulons réaffirmer
encore une fois le principe d'un système
solidaire par répartition qui existe
dans notre pays depuis le programme du
cnr
alors je crois qu'il est inutile de
créer de la confusion aujourd'hui et si
certains de nos concitoyens le
souhaitent
eh bien nous sommes toutes et tous libre
de recourir à ce type de produits
financiers si cela nous convient jour
merci merci madame auconie oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
tout d'abord monsieur rapporteur
permettez moi de saluer la qualité de
chacune de vos interventions vous êtes
vous avez beaucoup travaillé vos
dossiers vous en parler avec beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup d'engagement on n'est
pas toujours d'accord avec vos réponses
mais en tout cas moi j'apprécie
énormément la façon extrêmement
argumenté avec laquelle vous le faites
et je ne parlais pas je ne parlerai pas
ici de votre patience juste pour revenir
sur ce sujet moi je regarde ce qui se
fait parce que comme vous je suis
profondément européenne et je regarde ce
qui se fait dans les autres états
membres de l'union européenne en suède
en allemagne au royaume dans les royal
dans le royaume uni mais aussi dans
d'autres pays comme les etats unis le
japon et je mesure combien aujourd'hui
cet outil est un outil finalement
financier qui permet à la fois d'assurer
une diminution du poids financier
toujours plus important pesant sur les
actifs une bonification des pensions de
retraite mais et tout en répondant aux
besoins de l'économie en épargne longue
je pense que c'est pas deux systèmes qui
s'opposent mais au contraire qui permet
de nourrir le régime de croix un régime
de croissance ça mérite d'être regardée
et merci du débat qu'on aura plus tard à
ce sujet merci madame auconie monsieur
jumelles notre collègue nous a permis
d'avoir un débat éclairant parce qu'on
voit bien que ça mais la majorité en
grande difficulté ils se sont évertués
pendant plus d'une heure tout à l'heure
à nous dire vous inquiétez pas on touche
pas au système par répartition les 230
milliards d'euros c'est déjà beaucoup
le ministre le maire lorsqu'il a dit
qu'il fallait déverrouiller sa il a eu
tort
on va consolider tout ça et puis à la
faveur de votre amendement d'inspiration
européenne et même des d'inspiration
étasunienne vous et le rapporteur qui du
bon hockey
on peut pas adopter votre amendement
mais c'est quand même le sens dans
lequel on va aller et puis le ministre
qui dit a pas tabou on peut entendre ce
que vous dites mais bon vous comprendrez
bien qu'on est déjà dans la merde tout
le monde est opposé à notre projet et si
on met ça en plus dedans on n'a pas fini
de s'en tirer et donc c'est je trouve
que c'est c'est ce que j'appelle les
amendements de révélations pardon à
laisser monsieur jumelles s'appelle
moment de conclure de révélations et a à
ce moment du débat je voulais en
profiter et chers collègues
d'abord pour souligner la patience la
disponibilité
du rapporteur du titre 1 notre collègue
pourquoi et puis pour rendre un hommage
appuyé aux autres rapporteurs qui ne
vont pas vraisemblablement connaître le
jour de gloire parce que j'ai bien peur
que les autres titres n'arrive pas et
donc je voudrais rendre un hommage
appuyé aux rapporteurs qui ont été
désignés et qu'ils ne prendront pas la
parole durant ce débat mes respects
chers collègues avaient toujours été bon
camarade jumelles mais monsieur thibault
oui merci mais c'est le président moi
j'aurais voulu intervenir ça fait
quelques heures maintenant que nous
parlons qu'on revient régulièrement ce
sujet des plafonds de 120000 euros
de qui parle-t-on on parle de 1 % des
français 1 % des français qu'est ce que
prévoit chaque collègue je vous ai
écoutés depuis que cinq jours je vous
demande juste de l'écouté je prends pas
souvent la parole je pense je voulais
quand même un peu clarifiée situation
120000 euros qu'est ce qui va se passer
jusqu'à 120 mille euros je cotise à
hauteur de 28% au delà de 5000 euros
petit manger une cotisation
supplémentaire de 2 83% qui me donne
aucun droit qui me donne aucun droit non
et 2 83% au delà des 120 mille euros
c'est une cotisation de solidarité c'est
cotisation de solidarité
ensuite c'est une cotisation petit ne
déstabilisait pas monsieur thiébaut
aller visiter beau vous avez seule la
parole j'ai des droits ouverts jusqu'à
120 mille euros et ma retraite sera
prise en charge notre 120000 euros au
late 120000 euros
je paie une cotisation de solidarité de
2 83% qui m'ouvre aucun droit ce qu'il
faut aussi vous l'avez très bien dit à
cet après-midi chers collègues
c'est effectivement une classe de
personnes qui aujourd'hui ont
l'espérance de vie la plus longue
c'est à dire que si on déplafonné haut
niveau de l'année au niveau du service
et drones niveau de la pension de
retraite
il parie pèserait lourdement sur les
dépenses de la caisse de retraites
plafonné
c'est aussi s'assurer justement de
l'insularité une bonne répartition
budgétaire
sur l'ensemble des français en terme de
et partitions pas que c'est un pur sang
pèsent le plus lourd sur l'ensemble la
caisse de retraite étant donné que à
vivre très longtemps et avec des niveaux
de pension très élevé après c'est au
sujet de la capitalisation
enfin un moment donné faut arrêter le
perp ça existe depuis 2003 2003 et le
perp aujourd'hui la cible avait été
débouté c'est quand même cette catégorie
là qui font déjà du placement de bien
plus longtemps
ils nous ont pas attendus mais
radicalisation merci allez monsieur
vallot dire les choses avec plus de
précision que ce qui vient de re fait il
ya une part de cotisation contributive
qui créent des droits à la retraite et
une part non contributives mais cette
part non contributifs tout le monde
l'appelle pas que les hyper riches tout
le monde la paye la différence c'est
qu'au delà de 120 mille euros lorsqu'il
y avait une cotisation de 26 à un peu
plus de 26%
bah vous le ramener à 2 80 en fait vous
rendez vous 1 % de français les plus
riches et 4 milliards de cotisations a
valeur de 1000 25,4 milliards et puis
par ailleurs et puis par ailleurs je
vais revenir et puis par ailleurs comme
l était contributive et que nous sommes
dans un système par répartition ceux qui
sont à la retraite aujourd'hui qui veut
leur payer eh bien les 99% d'autres
français
c'est exactement ce qui va se passer par
ailleurs ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est que le la part contributive
l'appart non contributives pardon va
peser plus lourd
chez les indépendants qui parions une
une cotisation contributif plus
importante que les autres
ce qui veut dire qu'en été le rendement
ne sera pas le même pour les salariés et
pour les non salariés et j'ai posé la
question de savoir quel serait le rôle
le taux de rendement réel pour les
salariés et pour les indépendances j'ai
posé la question au ministre à plusieurs
et par tranches à plusieurs reprises on
n'a pas eu on n'a pas eu la réponse
voilà la réalité objective sur ce sur ce
cadeau que vous faites au 1 % français
les plus riches
merci monsieur dupont-aignan on revient
à cette question de la capitalisation
moi je voudrais faire deux remarques la
première c'est que la question n'est pas
de savoir s'il ya des systèmes de
capitalisation
la question est de savoir si la baisse
des pensions de retraite que vous
organisez à travers cette réforme ne va
pas inciter les français qui savent bien
que leur pension vont baisser si par
malheur cette réforme était adoptée à
souscrire à de nouveaux plans de
capitalisation
- rien ne me gênent s'il ya des
élections de capitalisation si on assure
une retraite digne à nos retraités par
la répartition mais là vous affaiblissez
le système par répartition et après vous
allez dire tiens c'est étonnant
il ya le développement des plans
d'épargné retraite et ses premiers
points
deuxième point vous y allez fort pour
les plus hauts revenus
après le chèque de 5 milliards pour
l'impôt sur la fortune voilà le chèque
de 4 milliards 5 milliards pour le 1%
les plus riches de france
c'est ahurissant et vous aller creuser
un déficit de 70 milliards d'euros alors
même qu'au même moment vous nous dit on
c'est horrible il ya un déficit de 100
milliards d'euros qui se profile et
c'est alors monsieur le rapporteur
après quinze questions hier et
avant-hier nous dit oui mais ça sera un
système par transition mais alors si les
parts transition ça veut dire que bien
évidemment vous reconnaissez qu'il ya un
problème majeur de financement donc de
toutes façons vous créez du déficit
alors même que vous vous plaignez du
déficit et vous créez du difficile pour
conduire les plus riches de france qui
sont un bon marché vers vos amis
assureurs v vos amis sur assureurs
blackrock qui passe sa vie à l'elysée on
sait qui a soutenu le président de la
république
on sait à qui renvoie la monnaie de sa
pièce le président d'adp merci monsieur
vigier bien beau très rapidement le seul
président le premier c'est concernant la
politique natalité tels que on a pu en
parler tout à l'heure et nathalie élima
c'était ce matin s'était livré un vrai
plaidoyer oui ça fait partie des
éléments de la compétitivité l'économie
française avait la chance d'être les
pays européens dans lequel on avait de
natalité le plus fort et on est en train
de passer sous les 2 donc il n'est pas
anormal sur veut solidifier la
répartition de faire en sorte qu' on
puisse justement qu'il faire en sorte
qu'ils aient une reconnaissance lorsque
les fans seront à la retraite c'est pour
ça qu'ils allaient bonifications et on
verra ça un peu plus tard sur les
articles mais c'est normal qu'on en
parle d'art clic l'heure parce qu'on
n'est pas tout à fait certains d'aller
au bout du chemin
ce répartition et capitalisation
franchement faut qu'on arrête d'avoir
des débats des faunes et le perdre comme
usé le collègue tout à l'heure c'est
depuis 2003 je rappelle la préfon la
préférence au lendemain de la guerre
qu'elle était mise en place
donc c'est pas un gros mot non plus donc
le fait qu'ils et lazartigues 82 dans
les entreprises article 83 les pertes
madelin tout cela ça existe depuis
longtemps dans ce qui est important
c'est le ministre et ça à mon avis il
faudrait vraiment vous éclaire y est
c'est que dans le texte et dans
l'article vous mis en place ensemble de
principes et vous évoquez l'expression
monsieur le ministre
une une retraite digne
avec un montant qui n'est pas précisée
et donc je crois que c'est important
c'est de repréciser les choses dans une
retraite par répartition une retraite
digne
ça veut dire quoi ça permettrait me
semble-t-il de lever un symptôme
d'obstacles de compréhension merci alors
monsieur le ministre et après en procès
de vote de cet amendement
merci monsieur le président je serais
cours simplement redire au président au
vivier que tout ce qu'il a évoqué en
matière de capitalisation
ce sont des dispositifs facultatifs nous
nous portons un projet de loi sur un
système obligatoire qui soit universelle
solidaire par répartition et par points
donc je confirme ce que je vous ai déjà
dit nous avons il existe dispositifs de
retraite par capitalisation sont des
régimes qui sont facultatifs qui sont
construits dans un autre cadre que celui
de notre socle intergénérationnel que
nous voulons défendre et préserver dans
lequel de ce projet de loi merci
monsieur mise alors nous mettons voix
l'amendement 96-57 présenté par un
avocat ni avis défavorable de monsieur
le ministre et de monsieur le rapporteur
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté nous mettons nous en
venons à la discussion
initié par l'amendement 23 851 de madame
rabot et il y a je le dis tout de suite
il y assure les sous-amendement 41 900
32,41 930 51 937 une demande
du groupe gdr de scrutin public
ces scrutins sont annoncées dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée madame la
présidente
merci monsieur le président alors comme
effectivement l'article 1 est un article
de principe sur l'ensemble des justement
des principes que vous souhaitez voir
intégrer à la réforme des retraites
notre collègue janicot propose d'ajouter
à la liste de ce que vous avez déjà
proposé la ligne à 11 du principe de la
constitution de 1946 et qui vise à dire
que la nation garantit aux retraités la
protection de la santé la sécurité
matérielle le repos et les loisirs
merci madame la présidente qui lie à des
sous-amendements le 41 932 me fais d'un
monsieur peu oui merci monsieur le
président nous simplement pour dire que
non seulement nous soutenons ces sept
cet amendement mais vous nous souhaitons
lui donner renforcer même la porter en
lui donnant un caractère solennel parce
que quand on lit le conseil l'avis du
conseil d'état que vous avez tous lu et
qu'on a ce passage que je cite très
brièvement de la part du conseil d'état
qui dit regretter les conditions dans
laquelle le gouvernement a saisi le
conseil d'état sur cette réforme des
retraites et qui précise cette situation
est d'autant plus regrettable que les
projets de loi procède à une réforme des
systèmes de retraite inédite depuis 1945
est destiné à transformer pour les
décennies à venir un système social qui
constitue l une des composantes majeures
du contrat social je finis de citer le
conseil d'état je pense que quand on est
devant une offensive aussi importante et
de remise en cause de notre contrat
social intégré des références à la
constitution de 46 qui restent jusqu'à
preuve du contraire la constitution
commune est un des fondements de notre
république me paraît non seulement
bienvenu mais je pense qu'on peut même
ont renforcé le caractère solennel c'est
le proposition de te sous un moment
merci autres sous-amendement le 41 935
monsieur d'arrivée merci monsieur
monsieur le président mon en effet la
première chose qui nous vient à l'esprit
en disant cet amendement c'est le regret
de voir effectivement le l'âge de départ
effectif à la retraite qui va s'éloigner
au fur et à mesure que le temps va
passer avec la réforme que vous proposez
or effectivement il nous semble que la
nation doit garantir aux retraités la
protection de la santé la sécurité
matérielle le repos et les loisirs c'est
à dire le droit a finalement être
libérée du travail prescrit et je crois
que ça c'est une dimension fondamentale
du droit à la retraite dans les débats
que nous avons eus en commission nous
avons eu quelques échanges sur cette
question certains nous disons mais enfin
nous croisons la plupart des gens autour
de nous qui veulent continuer à
travailler au delà de l'âge de départ à
la retraite etc
nous nous pensons que la retraite est
effectivement une forme de libération ça
veut pas dire qu'ils aient pas de
l'émancipation dans le travail mais nous
pensons que la retraite c'est un âge
dans lequel on peut justement être
libérée du travail prescrit et puis se
livrer à des activités plus choisis et
qui ne veut pas dire ça ne signifie pas
qu'il n'y a plus de travail
quand on est à la retraite mais c'est
sous une autre forme et je crois
qu'elles sont très utiles à la société
merci mais c'est harry ville le 41 937
monsieur villefranque
oui quelques mots quand même majeurs
pour abonder dans le sens de
l'amendement notre collègue jean nicot
on parle ici de santé et de sécurité
2 sérénité de la fin de vie cette
dernière tranche de la vie qu'est la
retraite et il nous paraît effectivement
fondamental de sanctuariser dans le
texte de loi
ces garanties fondamentales que la
nation doit à nos retraités il ne s'agit
pas là de questions superflues voir
superfétatoire mais bien un engagement
national au regard des travailleurs qui
sont devenus c'est retraités au niveau
national merci et madame fiat
le 49 131 132 merci monsieur le
président par ce sous-amendement nous
souhaitons substituer aux mots la
sécurité matérielle les mots un niveau
de vie décent par ce sous-amendement
nous souhaitons appuyé l'amendement
concernées et souligné par là même le
caractère profondément inégalitaire de
cette réforme qui va appauvrir les
populations les plus fragiles comme
depuis deux ans et demi à chaque fois
que vous nous inventer quelque chose
monsieur le ministre lors des de votre
première question au gouvernement
vous aviez une réponse un peu maladroite
ou vous nous aviez dit que ceux qui
n'ont pas réussi qui n'ont pas eu de
carrière ascendante vont gagner mais
c'est quoi réussir c'est quoi avoir une
carrière ascendante
personnellement je suis aide soignante
ascendante
hormis devenir infirmière ce dont je
n'ai pas envie sais c'est quoi
fayyad et métier où on en arrive à être
soignants et notre métier on les aime en
terminale soignants et ça veut pas dire
qu'on réussit pas bien au contraire se
faire toute une carrière en tant qu'aide
soignant c'est une très grande réussite
ou alors vous pensez comme madame muriel
pénicaud que maintenant une aide
soignante pourra devenir ébéniste j'ai
depuis croisé mon prof de techno de
collège qui m'a bien conseillé de ne
jamais tenir de ciseaux à bois c'est une
très mauvaise idée
concernant votre réponse à madame du
monde sur l'infirmière monsieur mini
jeux vous ai trouvé taquin avec notre
collègue dumont en disant que vous
preniez les salaires
que la fameuse infirmières gagnerait en
je peux pas vous donner de conseils
parce que ça pourrait très mal pris vu
gel du point d'indicé depuis des
décennies et depuis votre gouvernement
va falloir vite des gelées pour arriver
à ce que vous annoncez un mais alors la
va vite falloir appeler monsieur le
ministre verrons pour dire ont déjà eu
dès ce soir parce que sinon ça va pas
fonctionner merci mais la fiat alors des
amendements tendant à des amendements
des sous-amendements m'ont été adressées
par la suite le vôtre monsieur cinieri
le 42e 380 sa sous-amendement et
j'indique whisky les mois et jany que
vous m'avez fait parvenir également une
demande de scrutin public sur ce
sous-amendement oui mais il est annoncé
moi je voudrais rebondir sur
l'excellente amendement de mon collègue
juanico et puis je voudrais rajouter que
alors que nos concitoyens des
territoires ruraux rencontrent des
difficultés pour se soigner en raison
des déserts médicaux
il semble important de rappeler que
l'accès aux soins de telles garanties
retraités et sur l'alinéa 2 je voudrait
substituer aux mots la protection de
lesmo l'accès à tous compris un
amendement du forez alors le monsieur
monsieur cinieri alors monsieur le
monsieur le rapporteur sur ces
amendements et sous-amendement merci
monsieur le président que je ne peux que
que partager les intentions en tous les
cas sur sur le fond du du groupe
socialiste est porté par monsieur
genicot enfin ses collègues
pour autant ce que vous citez donc comme
vous le dites c'est le préambule de la
constitution de 46 et donc je vous
invite pendant les longues heures
de 2,2 des bardes heureux de revisiter
de relire votre constitution de 58 parce
que la constitution de 58 dans son
préambule rappelle le préambule de 46
donc le préambule de 46 et dans le bloc
de constitutionnalité de la constitution
de 58 et donc de ce fait s'applique à la
loi constitutionnelle et donc de ce fait
il serait il serait le maître dans le
texte de loi seraient eux
en affaiblir et d'une certaine façon la
porte et c'est dans la constitution donc
de fait votre amendement et est
satisfait donc défaveur monsieur le
ministre j'ai un avis défavorable
monsieur le président comme le
rapporteur dira même caroline fiat que
je les remercie de porter attention à
mes réponses aux questions au
gouvernement peut-être d'être aussi
attentives à leur teneur que je ne
considère pas et je sais pas du plus que
j'ai dit d'ailleurs que je considère pas
que c'est réussir dans sa vie que de
changer de métier que l'on peut avoir
des satisfactions affaire est toujours
le même métier si on le souhaite et que
est par contre ce qui est sûr c'est que
quand on a une carrière ascendante on
est favorisés par le système actuel
et quand on a une carrière plate on est
défavorisée par la retraite actuel
monsieur le président si monsieur le
ministre
alors j'ai plusieurs demandes
d'intervention d'abord monsieur petit
alors mohammadi un peu gêné parce que
pour moi cet amendement ne fait que
reprendre les dispositions de l'article
l 111 2 1
d'ailleurs l'article cité puisqu'il
parle la nation affirme l attachement au
caractère universel obligatoire et
solidaire de la prise en charge des
frais de santé assurés par la sécurité
sociale c'est déjà dans le texte pour
que l'on rajoute quelques jours a
effectivement dans le texte il n'ya pas
le repos les loisirs mais il me semble
que cet amendement il rempli par les
dispositions du texte qui est la linea
dont on fait référence dans l'article 1
les principes généraux donc je pense
qu'il suffit de lire l'article et votre
amendement et et correspond tout à fait
à ce que vous souhaitez merci monsieur
du corps aignan oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je trouve
que cet amendement a le mérite de
revenir aux réalités et encore une fois
j'ai le sentiment que notre assemblée
est un peu hors sol est alors comme je
un côté peut-être opiniâtre ou du moins
casse pieds je veux rappeler que s'il ya
que 30%
deux personnes en activité entre 60 et
64 ans c'est pas par hasard
bien sûr qu'est le problème de la crise
économique et à la difficulté à trouver
un emploi mais il ya surtout le fait que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé est de
60 g le chiffre exact 63 ans 1,4 pour
les hommes 60 ans pour un ouvrier même
moins 64 ans 5 po les femmes et donc est
ce que la collectivité nationale comme
pour seul objectif de conduire les
français à la retraite quand ils sont
malades
je suis un peu provocateur mais cela
montre une régression sociale
incroyable par rapport à la déclaration
dès 1946 de ce qu'étaient nos
prédécesseurs il ya 75 ans et à partir
du moment où on estime que la france a
quand même une richesse collective forte
est ce que est ce qu'on doit aujourd'hui
se dire on prend comme acquis qu'on
s'aligne sur des politiques qui ont
échoué ailleurs car si on lille l'étude
d'impact on voit bien que votre seule
référence sont les grandes orientations
de politique européenne
c'est cette espèce de mots manie de
vouloir imiter l'allemagne et les autres
pays alors à le allons en allemagne voir
ce qui se passe pour les retraités
le désastre allons en suède où vous avez
des manifestations de retraités tous les
jours suite à l'établissement du système
à points mais c'est ça que nous voulons
collectivement c'est ça que nous
préparons pour nos jeunes générations
qui travaillent moi j'estime qu'on peut
faire mieux je ne suis pas d'accord
toujours avec des projets d'une retraite
à 60 ans total parce que je pense que ce
n'est pas finançable
mais en revanche nous nous proposons de
60 ans pour les métiers pénibles à 62
ans c'est déjà c'est déjà un bel
objectif et je crois qu'on s'honorerait
à prévoir 14% du pib' 14% du pis pour
nos retraités sachant qu'il ya le défi
de la dépendance qui viendra après et
nous aurons besoin cet égard de la crds
quand elle s'épuisera en 2024 et ses 24
milliards de crédits annuels seront bien
utiles pour aider nos retraités à
affronter la dépendance merci même
panneau merci monsieur le président je
voulais revenir parce qu'il ya de
nombreux collègues qui parle de la
capitalisation qui existe déjà en france
notamment avec le système agirc arrco la
réalité c'est que c'est un très mauvais
exemple à prendre puisque ce notamment
quand on prend la valeur de la pension
moyenne pour
système agir on arrive entre 2006 et
2016 à une baisse de 16 4% de cette
valeur des pensions moyennes donc ça
montre bien et d'ailleurs vous êtes
incapable à chaque fois qu'on vous pose
la question de nous citer un seul pays
qui a mis la retraite à points sans
arriver par l'art à la retraite par
capitalisation et un doublement voire un
triplement du nombre de retraités
pauvres dans le pays et d'ailleurs vous
ne vous en cachez pas puisque vous avez
décoré de la légion d'honneur le patron
français de la croque et c'est
d'ailleurs blackrock qui devrait plutôt
vous remercier de 2,7 de ce cadeau que
vous êtes en train de leur faire je sais
pas pourquoi vous exciter à ce point là
c'est eux c'est complètement connu c'est
faux c'est faux vous n'avez pas donné la
légion d'honneur en patron français de
rock c'est pas faux halal et pas
n'importe quoi maintenant
même pas le deuxième des chaussées je
vais terminer la terre la deuxième des
chaussées une collègue a parlé de la
liberté les français et les françaises
auraient la liberté de faire appel au
système de capitalisation
mais moi j'ai envie de vous demander
c'est quoi la liberté que lorsqu'il n'y
a plus de pension digne c'est la liberté
d'aller au restaurant du coeur c'est la
liberté de continuer à travailler
jusqu'à 76 ans dans des boulots de merde
c'est c'est quoi cette liberté oui c'est
le titre du livre que je vous citais
tout à l'heure donc ne vous en effrayer
pas autant c'est la liberté peut-être de
rush est séché par an lorsque chez ces
enfants pardon lorsque on a plus assez
d'argent ou plus assez d'autonomie pour
pouvoir vivre seul ou dans des moyens
qui sont seuls donc concrètement non ce
n'est pas une liberté d'ailleurs vous
auriez bien d'autres moyens de faire de
faire rentrer de l'argent dans les
caisses de retraite nous vous l'avons
dit à plusieurs reprises notamment
augmenter les salaires seulement de 1%
seulement de 1% ferait rentrer 2 5
milliards dans les caisses de retraite
c'est maladroit à viriat mots d'abord
nos collègues ont raison de rappeler que
là où la retraite par points a été mise
en place à côme et des dégâts
considérables
je rappelais tout à l'heure à quel point
les allemands étaient contraints de
faire une réunion de crise pour en
assumer les conséquences notamment en
termes d'aggravation de la pauvreté mais
je trouve que même si l'explication
juridique du rapporteur et et
solide que l'amendement de nos camarades
socialistes n'est pas redondant parce
que moi j'ai le souvenir d'un ministre
enfin d'un rapporteur devenu ministre
depuis quelques jours on n'a pas vu au
banc depuis qu'il est ministre qui
envisageait au moment de la réforme de
la constitution ne faire parts sortir le
mot sécurité sociale de la constitution
et de le sud de lui substituer le mot
protection sociale ce qui n'est
évidemment pas vous en doutez la même
signification la même garantie la même
connotation historique et donc se
référer au préambule de 46 au moment où
nous appréhendons la réforme des
retraites pour an réaffirmer les
principes fondamentaux est une garantie
pour nous prémunir d'un ministre qui
rêve
au bout du compte de débarrasser du
texte fondamental la protection de
sécurité qu'embrasse croisa a décidé de
graver dans le sang et les larmes de la
libération donc un amendement qui au
bout du groupe n'est pas aussi
superfétatoire que cela merci monsieur
val aux nues le président ne disconvient
du fait que en effet c'est dans le bloc
de constitutionnalité et que ce que nous
proposons de mettre ce sont des
objectifs à valeur constitutionnelle
sanou dégraderait pas la hiérarchie des
normes et l'autorité attaché à ses
objectifs mais sa soul in iz ray d'une
certaine manière les exigences qui sont
les nôtres depuis 1946 et qui nous
paraît à certains égards menacé par le
reste des dispositions de votre loin
quand j'évoque par exemple la sécurité
dus aux vieux travailleurs
évidemment il ya des motifs d'inquiétude
je me souviens du président emmanuel
macron et il avait très très tout à fait
raison lorsqu'il a indiqué que ce serait
pure hypocrisie que de déplacer l'âge de
départ effectif à la retraite tant qu'
on n'aurait pas gagné la bataille de
l'emploi des seniors vous n'avez pas
gagné la bataille de l'emploi des
seniors est donc pour surmonter pour une
part cette hypocrisie balle nous
proposant d'inscrire dans cette loi
c'est exigeant dans cette maison commune
c'est avec un certain nombre de ces
principes
merci monsieur saint martin merci
monsieur président juste brièvement
parce qu'effectivement une petite
musique qui ne faudrait pas laisser
courir sur le ministre de la santé
solidarité fait qu'il aurait supprimé
l'expression de sécurité sociale donc
juste remettre une vérité parce qu'elle
importante parce que les gens nous
regardent dans la révision
constitutionnelle avait une proposition
d'élargir les champs de la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale en
remplaçant 8 occurrence sur neuf du
terme sécurité sociale par protection
sociale pour une raison simple pour
pouvoir mettre les sujets de dépendance
qui seront des sujets extrêmement
important ici la fin du quinquennat dans
le champ des lois du plfss
donc non non ne ment pas et on ne dit
pas qu'il ya une volonté de supprimer le
terme de sécurité sociale de la part de
l'ancien rapporteur de cette loi
alors nous allons maintenant procéder au
vote des jumelles vous êtes exprimés
rappels au règlement
d'accord mais sinon je ne peux pas vous
donner la parole sur le fondement de
l'article son alinéa 5
c'est vous qui l'avez écrit l'ancien
président vous vous devez donc le
connaître personne ne m'en ici
lorsqu'il rappelle qu'en pleine affaire
benalla la réforme avortée de la
constitution comporter un amendement de
monsieur vers ans qui visait à
substituer aux mots sécurité sociale le
mot de protection sociale est d'ailleurs
dans l'esprit de nombreuses phrases à la
sécurité sociale intégrée y compris les
problématiques de vieillissement
mais évidemment est donc rappelé la stib
a menti rappelé à ses rappeler une
vérité savait d'ailleurs suscité un
débat très important commission mer
cimer de l'hiver les importants qui
avait conduit verront à la relation
humaine
on va procéder maintenant au vote des
flous amendement puisque à une demande
de scrutin public qui a été fait
le 41 930,2 je vais laisser chacun
organise sa place
le 41 932 le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat votants 95 exprimés 85 majorité
43 pour 14 contre 71 il est rejeté
le 41 935 de monsieur jumelles également
scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
résultat votants 95 exprimés 85 majorité
43 pour 14 contre 71 il est rejeté le
cas on tient 937 de monsieur jumelles
scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
résultat 4-1 15 votants 84 exprimé
majorité 43 pour 14 contre 70 je met
maintenant à main levée l'amendement de
madame panneaux le cas en 232 qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté je mets au voit maintenant
le calme de 382 monsieur cinieri
scrutins publics demandés le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est clos votants 93 exprimé
87 majorité 44 pour 18 contre 69 jeu
mais l'amendement de monsieur jouhaud
nico on voit le 23 851 qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est rejeté madame rabot madame la
présidente vous avez le 25 42 monsieur
le président c'est un moment vise à
supprimer les alinéa 4 à 11 du l'article
1er pas parce que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec les alinéas que vous
pouvez défendre mais parce que la
réalité du texte fait que les
dispositions que vous prenez ne sont pas
cohérentes ou en accord avec les
objectifs qui sont proposés ainsi je
vais juste en cités un par exemple
alinéa 8 vous proposer un objectif de
liberté de choix pour les assurés leur
permettant sous réserve d'un âge minimum
de décider de leur date de départ à la
retraite
alors là là dessus c'est quand même une
belle hypocrisie puisque à partir du
moment où et fixer un âge déquilibre le
choix que vous offrez aux assurés
lorsqu'ils prennent à leurs autres sens
lorsqu'ils atteignent l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite c'est soit d'avoir
une retraite amputée de 5 10 % de son
montant soit de travailler un ou deux
ans de plus ça ça s'appelle pas la
liberté
en tout cas on pourrait faire une
dissertation philosophique là dessus ça
ne s'appelle pas la liberté aussi pour
prévoir un objectif de liberté de choix
pour les assurés tels que l'on vous
l'écrivez n'est pas cohérent avec ce que
vous proposez comme disposition donc
c'est pour ça que nous vous proposons de
supprimer les alinéas quatre à onze de
cet article merci madame la présidente
je me suis le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président mes jeux je
rappelle la constitution de tout texte
de loi qui a souvent général un
préambule un article premier donc c'est
les objectifs je comprends que vous ne
partagiez pas les outils mis au service
de cet objectif mais là en l'occurrence
vous supprimez l'objectif d'équité pour
essayer de d'apporter des solutions les
plus équitables entre assurés en matière
de retraites et notamment en matière de
cotisations vous supprimer de fait un
objectif de solidarité et notamment la
résorption des écarts des retraites
entre les femmes et les hommes la prise
en compte des périodes d'interruption et
de réduction d'activité je vais pas tout
lister vous supprimez l'objectif d'un
garante d'un de garantie d'un niveau de
vie satisfaisant qui avait été intégré
dans le projet de loi too touraine vous
supprimer cet objectif de liberté de
choix pour les assurés alors bien sûr
c'est liberté de choix sous sous sous
contrainte à partir d'un âge à partir
d'un âge légal et à partir d'un hd qui
vibre c'est et puis un objectif de
soutenabilité économique parce que la
garantie la plus forte qu'on peut donner
à nos concitoyens que eux-mêmes seul et
les actuels cotisants et notamment les
plus jeunes puissent en bénéficier c'est
que ce système soit équilibré à l'avenir
et enfin un objectif de lisibilité des
droits parce que je le dis je le redirai
et je veux leur dire à de nombreuses
reprises le système actuel qui s'appuie
sur 42 régime avec des modes de calcul
différente suivant des points suivants
des trimestres suivants des valeurs
portées au compte ou pas n'est
absolument illisible pour la plupart de
nos concitoyens donc défavorable
martial ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente valérie rabault sur le fond
j'ai un avis qui va être proche de celui
du rapporteur mais en même temps que je
relisais votre amendement
je vise en fait l'idée c'est quoi c'est
de reprendre le préambule la
constitution 46 et quand je regarde les
dispositions de jurisprudence moi je
pense que ça serait affaiblir ce
principe de valeur constitutionnelle que
le réécrire au niveau de la loi
voilà pourquoi j'ai un avis défavorable
mais dans le président merci
alors j'ai ma même du monde monsieur le
ministre pardonnez moi mais je pense que
vous avez fait erreur que vous parliez
de l'amendement précédent soffer mais
l'erreur est humaine non pour revenir
sur notre amendement
écoutez ça fait des jours et des jours
qu'on ses poumons pour essayer de
démontrer combien cette soi-disante
réforme est injuste
et pourtant à l'extérieur tout le monde
l'a bien compris et donc vous vous
n'arrêtez pas de dire des bâtons des
bâtons moi je vous dis qu'à l'extérieur
ils entendent des bâtons en deux mots un
des bateaux dans le cadre de cette
réforme
et donc quand on lit ces objectifs de
l'article 1 qui est l'article des
principes on pose le principe équité
solidarité garantie d'une d'un niveau de
vie satisfaisant liberté de choix et
qu'il est financier lisibilité des
droits on voit bien quand on va lire un
petit peu plus loin que ses objectifs ne
pourront pas être atteindre avec le
projet de loi que vous avez écrit et
donc comme il ya une contradiction
absolument flagrante entre ses objectifs
énoncés dans l'article 1 et la suite
quand vous propose de supprimer les
objectifs
madame rabbo a évoqué l'objectif de la
liberté de choix moi je reprends un
exemple sur l'équité avec toujours le
cas d'un ouvrier par exemple qui
commencerait à travailler à 20 ans qui
cotisent pendant 43 je répète qu'il
pourra partir avec une retraite à taux
plein à 60 3 ans donc c'est un an de
plus que l'âge légal mais c'est deux de
moins que l'âge déquilibre et donc
il aura un malus de 10% sur sa pension à
vie
a contrario le cadre qui commence par
exemple à travailler à 24 parce qu'il a
fait des études qui cotisent toujours 43
c'est à dire la même durée que l'ouvrier
il partira à la retraite à 67 donc deux
ans de plus que l'âge déquilibre
bénéfices 10 % de bonus
toute sa vie donc naples et passe à
l'équité je ne reviens pas sur la
solidarité d'autres y reviendront sans
doute mais voilà pourquoi on vous
propose de supprimer les objectifs
affichés qui ne pourront pas être
atteints atteint avec les articles qui
suivent
merci merci monsieur dharréville oui
merci monsieur le président vient ici
vous affichez un certain nombre
d'objectifs qui peuvent au premier abord
paraître désirable mais qui en réalité
pour une part d'entre eux d'ailleurs ne
le sont pas toujours
enfin je vais les décortiquer un parent
si vous me permettez d'abord un objectif
d'équité afin de garantir aux assurés
que chaque euro cotisé ou vous les mêmes
droits j'ai déjà critiqué cette formule
parce que sous des dehors comme ça
qu'ils paraissent assez généreux en
réalité c'est une formule qui revient au
chacun pour soi
ensuite un objectif de solidarité au
sein de chaque génération par la
résorption des écarts de retraite entre
les femmes et les hommes etc etc
tout ça nous avons pu démontrer dans la
première partie de notre discussion
ça ne correspondait pas à la réalité
troisièmement d'objectifs de garantie
d'un niveau de vie satisfaisant aux
retraités
moi je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire
dans la loi un niveau de vie
satisfaisant
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là
exactement est-ce que vous engagez sur
un taux de remplacement pas le moins du
monde
donc votre taux de votre niveau de vie
satisfaisant mais quelque part c'est une
guirlande pour décorer mais ça n'a
aucune
aucun impact réel un objectif de liberté
de choix monsieur le rapporteur vient de
dire lui-même sous contrainte
ça veut tout dire effectivement il
s'agit de pousser les gens à travailler
plus longtemps donc à l'assureur
supprimé de la pension cinquième
objectif soutenabilité économique
garantie notamment par des cotisations
et contributions équitablement répartis
entre les assurés ça n'est pas le cas on
voit bien qu'avec votre affaire des
trois passes 8 passes déjà il ya une
entorse à ce à ce cet objectif
enfin sixième objectif lisibilité des
droits n est pas au rendez vous c'est le
flou le plus complet ya aucun engagement
de ce point de vue là y'a aucun objectif
en fait qui tient la route dans ce que
vous nous proposez de moi je comprends
que nos collègues socialistes et
souhaitez vous rendre service en
supprimant ses objectifs qui ne
correspondent pas à votre texte c'est du
tuning merci monsieur petit si monsieur
le président moi je crois qu'il vaudrait
mieux laisser les objectifs si on veut
un vrai travail parlementaire
on laisse les objectifs et vous nous
aideriez dans les articles concernés à
amender pour les atteindre
mais moi je voudrais je voudrais revenir
sur autre chose je voudrais revenir sur
sur les cent vingt mille euros et les
trois passes moi je vais prendre des
exemples parce que je crois qu'il ya des
gens qui ne ne suis pas sûr qu'on soit
qu'on parle tous bien des mêmes choses
je prends quelqu'un qui gagne 180000
euros dans le système d'aujourd'hui il
en met 6 au régime général
6000 euros régime général et après pour
lui pour le régime complémentaire
il en met environ 30 de hockey une
partie sur sa tranche à et puis le reste
sur sa tranche b jusqu'à 180 milles
effectivement jusqu'à 180 milles dans le
nouveau système
ils payent ils payent ils payent 28 %
jusqu'à 120 mille euros ce qui fait
qu'il y à 34 milles euros qui viennent
dans le régime général au lieu de six je
répète il y à 34 milles euros qui
viennent dans le régime général au lieu
de six et ils continuent à payer pour la
solidarité
encore deux ou trois ça dépend le 2,8 g
pas calculé peut-être très rapidement
donc donc quelqu'un qui paye 180000
euros
il ne manque quasiment rien la seule
différence c'est qu'au lieu de mettre
six dans le régime général il en mai 34
merci
allez je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement de madame rabot le 25 42
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté nous en venons à des
amendements identiques ou madame auteur
madame panneaux merci monsieur le
président alors on va continuer la
discussion qui a été amorcée par les
collègues socialistes puisque cette
année les 1/4 que nous voulons supprimer
porte sur l'universalité du régime de
retraite que vous souhaitez 1,6
instituée alors pour le coup ça ça fait
partie des éléments de langage qui
tombent petit à petit au fur et à mesure
que nous étudions cette réforme puisque
sont exclus de ce régime universel
d'ores et déjà les routiers d'ores et
déjà le personnel navigant aérien
certaines fonctions régaliennes sous
réserve d'avoir effectué des missions
d'une dangerosité particulière donc ça
devrait concerner les policiers et les
pompiers professionnels s'engagent et
déjà exclu les gardiens de prison et les
douaniers les militaires et les
gendarmes et est donc on voit bien qu'on
en arrive là avec un élément qui est
complètement vide de sens et que si ce
système était aussi merveilleux vous
voyez le dire il n'y aurait pas besoin
d' exclure tant de personnes bon
finalement ce système n'est pas
universel non plus puisque il instaure
un régime spécial pour les riches on en
parlait tout à l'heure
puisque ces derniers nés opérante
presque plus de cotisations au delà
220000 euros et il n'est une pas non
plus universel pour les femmes qui vous
le savez en les carrières les plus âgés
ont des salaires qui sont de 25% en
moyenne moindre que les hommes et que
d'ores et déjà dans le système actuel et
ça va encore s'aggraver avec le système
que vous allez mettre en place un tiers
des retraités qui cumule retraités
emplois sont des femmes avec des
pensions inférieur en moyenne à 883
euros et donc qu'ils sont forcés ou
libre peut-être diraient certains et
certaines de faire des ménages de l'aide
à domicile des services à la personne et
je passe donc ce système n'a absolument
rien d'universel il va faire travailler
les gens plus longtemps pour moins
d'argent
merci j'indique que madame panneaux sur
le 1642 est identique
il y à une demande de scrutin public il
est annoncé dans dans l'assemblée c'est
une demande du groupe
la france a soumis ce monsieur le
rapporteur non je je je considère que la
suppression alinéa par alinéa et n'a pas
de sens démocratique par rapport au
travail que nous devons faire donc donc
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président oui pardon madame la
présidente
bravo pour tout à l'heure mais madame la
députée du nom avait rectifié mon erreur
et je vous remercie de votre
bienveillance sur le sujet sur
l'amendement de madame au t1 madame
autant je reprenais simplement le texte
de loi s'est défendu permet même pas
nous parlons mais le texte de loi
proposé de supprimer le quatrième alinéa
quatrième l'idéal si on supprime
l'article plus rien dire donc ça peut
être que défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre alors
monsieur potier je soutiens cet
amendement comme je souhaitais
évidemment celui de ma collègue valérie
rabault pour une raison très simple on
en train d'afficher des objectifs dont
on n'a pas la preuve que les moyens sont
cohérents avec leur mise en oeuvre
moi j'ai peut-être peu d'expérience mais
j'en ai une celle du présent de
communautés de communes qui a mis en
oeuvre pour une des premières en france
l'atom incitatives pour les spécialistes
des politiques de déchets en application
du grenelle et de la tgap
on n'a pas affiché des grands résultats
on va réduire les déchets réduire les
inégalités
on a fait des simulations des
simulations foyer par foyer par
typologie par type de maison il y avait
trois enfants il veut une grand mère il
y avait dix enfants il y avait et c'est
en étant locatif en propriété
on a fait des simulations et quand on a
eu une belle arbres de simulation non
pas des ordonnances non pas une mauvaise
étude d'impact mais des vrais simulation
six mois de travail
on a affiché fièrement nos objectifs
réduire les déchets réduire les
inégalités ne pas peser sur le pouvoir
de vivre de nos concitoyens et nous
avons réussi et c'est pour ça que la
méthode que nous proposons c'est faire
la réalité des moyens et leur adéquation
qui est mise en oeuvre et c'est le
contraire de ce qui est affiché
aujourd'hui
et puis enfin je veux dire sur le
caractère universel dire à notre
collègue que non une politique qui
plafonne à 120000 euros et j'ai compris
entendus même les arguments de la cfdt
qui disait qu'elle était sur le plan
climatique arithmétique profitable moi
je réitère que une politique comme le
disait le président du conseil
départemental michel dinet qui est un de
mes maîtres en politique une politique
pour les moins riches devient une pauvre
politique à terme nos politiques doivent
être universel et c'est la progressivité
de la taxe qui doit permettre de
rattraper les inégalités générées je
milite pour ma part et c'est d'un sens
d'un amendement que je déposerai que le
groupe socialiste pour une grosse civile
pour une progressivité de la part de
solidarité ou même de la participation
elle même retraites qui pourrait passer
de 25 à 30 2 aurions alors à rétribution
égale un véritable instrument de
réduction des inégalités ne serions pas
dans cet avis
charges qui reste correspond comme le
dit si bien notre collègue d'harry ville
à du tuning monsieur servile non
attendez attendez attendez mais servent
ils
merci merci président après une semaine
passée dans l'hémicycle je vais repartir
de là matin à cayenne je vais fermer
sept mille kilomètres hebdomadaires avec
un goût amer et un sentiment de travail
totalement inachevé pourtant j'ai évité
de regarder le doigt du savant
lorsqu'ils montraient la lune parce que
je considérais que n'étant pas un
spécialiste de la question
il est impératif que je sois à l'ecoute
pour tenter de comprendre les tenants et
aboutissants de ce dossier
effectivement j'ai entendu beaucoup de
contradictions
j'ai entendu beaucoup d' analyse sur un
sujet complexe et surtout sur un sujet
qui de toute évidence a été très très
mal préparée je me suis référé aux avis
du conseil d'état je me suis référé aux
avis des organisations syndicales j'ai
entendu les personnels les personnels
d'éducation
j'ai entendu les avocats j'ai entendu
les paysans j'ai entendu un petit peu
tout le monde et aujourd'hui j'ai aussi
entendu la vie qui a été formulée par la
présidente de la haute autorité pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
qui est dit que son inquiétude par
rapport à l'état de ce texte est donc
tout ça me fait penser que en réalité
comme l'on dit de nombreux collègues
avant moi ce projet fait lourdement une
parfaite et une très belle unanimité que
contre lui et je voudrais vous dire
qu'au lait qu' effectivement je peux me
faire une idée plus précise ce soir pour
affirmer que ce projet n'est pas
universel que ce projet n'est pas
équitable que ce projet n'est pas juste
que ce projet n'est pas solidaire et que
ce projet il n'est pas non plus sincères
pour pouvoir expliquer illustrer le sens
de mon propos je voudrais simplement
vous demandé d'analyser la manière dans
les français d outre-mer sont traités
dans ce projet de loi initié quasiment
pas à telle enseigne que
la délégation autre mère avait sollicité
la mise en place d'une mission flash et
qui a abouti à la création d'un comité
de suivi et de négociation qui devra
comprendre son sein bien évidemment bien
d autres maires président permettez
c'est la première fois que je prends à
part mettre d'accord mais tout le monde
mais je vais essayer d'aller jusqu'au
bout de ma logique vous n'avez pas ou
alors j'ai pas interdire adresse
spéciale c'est vrai alors je vais été
heureusement pourquoi ce niveau mais je
veux leur montrer la moindre manche
suivante c'est le mot pour dire mais
dans ces conditions m 3 qui est bon et
juste un
alors monsieur madame autun
oui monsieur le président on repense l'a
immédiatement à ces propos de george
orwell qui disait le discours politique
est destinée à donner aux mensonges
c'est pour voir si vous écoutez vous
connaissez la suite les bien connus
cette phrase l'accent de la vérité et à
donner l'apparence de la solidité un
simple courant d'air et je pense que
cette phrase correspond parfaitement
parfaitement aux grands principes qui
sont posées dans ce texte parce que
c'est pour donner l'apparence d'une
réforme juste équitable solidaire
universel que vous affichez ses mots
dans un texte qui au départ prend cet
accent là d'un point de vue discursif
mais qui dans la réalité de ces
propositions concrètes se fracasse sur
le mur de ce régime à points qui n'a
rien d'universel rien de juste rien
d'acquis table et rien de solidaires
donc c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre
vous ironisé sur le fait que nous
supprimons l'alinéa 4 de ses grands
principes et l'alinéa 4 c'est
précisément celui qui dit nous posons de
grands principes et en effet en effet
nous avons ici un débat de fond qui est
peu ton politiquement se présenter
devant les français avec un texte qui
affiche des principes qui sont
contraires à ce qu'il ya dans le projet
de loi est une de nos collègues disait
cet après midi qu'il fallait être à la
hauteur des attentes des français en
l'occurrence je pense que leur mentir de
la sorte n'est pas être à la hauteur des
français
merci alors nous allons maintenant
procéder au vote je vous rappelle qu'à
une demande de scrutin public sur ces 17
amendements identiques
allez
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
votants 86 exprimé 74 majorité de 38
pour 12 contre 62 ils sont rejetés
non mais y aller elle est de droit
monsieur jumelles mais la demande je
vous propose trois minutes monsieur
jumelles trois minutes
ces reprises le 11 1291 madame la
députée oui merci monsieur le président
donc c'est un amendement de notre
collègue brun qui vise à supprimer bien
entendu le mot universel
outre que cette réforme est
incompréhensible pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens qu'elle est injuste qu'elle
est inéquitable qu'elle est non
solidaire et qu'elle est insoutenable
financièrement je pense qu'il
conviendrait d'être plus clair et
surtout beaucoup plus sincère dans les
termes employés
effectivement il n'ya plus rien
d'universel dans ce texte il y à de
nombreuses incohérences vous supprimez
les régimes spéciaux par des régimes
spécifiques
soyons donc honnête et supprimer le mot
universel de ce texte
merci madame valentin le en 1292 mais ce
que signifie non monsieur matin merci
monsieur le président comme je viens de
le dire brillamment ma collègue isabelle
valentin est comme gelée déjà dit
précédemment je trouve que le mot
universel est devenu particulièrement
inadapté entre le jour où il a pu être
annoncé et le résultat dans lequel nous
arrivons aujourd'hui puisque de nombreux
régimes dits spécifiques ont été
inventés qui maintiennent en fin de
compte le système que nous avons
aujourd'hui de régimes spéciaux tout en
permettant de perdre sur la retraite que
l'on touchera un jour peut-être
alors monsieur matin que vous avez été
bref je ne dirai rien parce que vous
n'étiez pas signataires de cet
amendement
c'était monsieur finir immigrés a été
bref et on considère que c'est qu'il a
été présenté le 24 916 madame
madame dumont ou madame rabot est
défendu même rabot bas la présidente
alors cet amendement vise à supprimer à
l'alinéa 4 le terme universel ce que je
crois qu'on en a déjà beaucoup débattu
mais en fait c'est pas un régime
universel il ya autant de régimes que
deux générations qui vont rentrer dans
le régime
donc par conséquent c'est difficile
d'appeler ça universel merci je vous
donne la parole me furent importants
monsieur je vais vous donner la parole
après monsieur petit monsieur le
rapporteur sur ces amendements
identiques
je crois que l'on s'est largement
exprimée à ce sujet à défavorable
monsieur le ministre je ferai comme chez
président défavorable merci monsieur le
monsieur petit pour rappel règlement oui
toujours le même voilà je je trouve que
c'est ce qui vient d'être dit je sais
pas ce que c'est quand on fait de la loi
quand on fait du travail parlementaire
je vois pas comment on peut parler de
sincérité et d'honnêteté ou bien ça veut
dire qu'on nous accuse d'être malhonnête
dans ces cas là il faut nous le dire
c'est par amalgame comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est pas dirigée contre mais ou
bien on nous accuse ou bien on parle de
ce qui est dans le texte mais on dit pas
qu'un mot est sincère ou pas donc je je
refuse à partir de maintenant ça fait
deux ans que je supporte ça je refuse
qu'on nous adresse par amalgame je ne
vois pas comment je vais la mode c'est
vous le veut le règlement le règlement
interdit qu'on me dise que je suis
malhonnête
voilà allez le règlement interdit qu'on
me dise que je suis malhonnête pour que
je suis un suppôt des banques ou que je
suis un une secte et ces mêmes valeurs
n'avez pas le droit de le dire même
valentin alors je suis désolé si vous
l'avez pris pour vous on ne vous a pas
dit que vous étiez malhonnête on a dit
que le texte était malhonnête un sincère
alors je mets aux voix ces amendements
identiques
le 24 916 et ses avis défavorable de
monsieur
le rapporteur et de monsieur le ministre
il n'y a pas de demandes de scrutins
publics donc le vote se fera à main
levée qui est pour et qui est contre
ils sont rejetés amendement donnant lieu
à une discussion commune le 22 696 alors
je vieillis fiq qui peut le présenter
monsieur matin vous pouvez le présenter
à madame valentin valentin oui ou alors
la communication politique n'a pas sa
place dans ce texte un énoncé erroné ne
peut graver dans le marbre de la loi
l'intitulé du texte ne peut être en
décalage avec son contenu compte tenu
des multiples dérogations d'ores et déjà
octroyé compte tenu qu'il est possible
de contester légitimement l'idée qu'un
euro cotisé donnera les mêmes droits ne
serait-ce que du simple point de vue des
différences d'espérance de vie en
fonction des carrières compte tenu que
le niveau minimum de retraite pourra
être comme c'est déjà le cas sans aucun
lien avec les droits ouverts l'emploi du
terme universel et donc inapproprié
il faut préférer la clarté clarté dont
on a besoin et à laquelle ont droit nos
concitoyens aussi il convient de
dénommer le futur nos régimes de
retraite en fonction de ses
caractéristiques principales
incontestable régime de retraite par
répartition et par points merci
amendements nous sommes sur les
amendements lieu à une discussion
commune monsieur dupont-aignan
oui monsieur le président monsieur
ministre à l'alinéa 5 je propose de
subtilité substituer pardon au mot
équité qu'est le mot valise de tous les
renoncements qui n'est pas un mot que
j'estime très républicain le mot
d'égalité de fraternité
pourquoi égalité fraternité parce que
une politique que des retraites devrait
permette l'égalité l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes qui n'est pas du
tout acquis par sept par votre réforme
et on l'a prouvé au cours de la
discussion
la suppression des huit trimestres des
huit trimestres par enfant et bien
évidemment vous l'oubliez quand vous
faites des comparaisons et d'ailleurs il
n'ya pas de simulation dans l'étude
d'impact parce que bien évidemment si
vous aviez mis des simulations sur les
femmes ayant eu des enfants vous
ries aperçu que le régime est
défavorable c'est mathématique
le deuxième point sur lequel je veux
encore insisté c'est pour le mot
fraternité pour notre nation et j'ai
retrouvé parce que j'en ai parlé à
plusieurs reprises mais je n'avais plus
le dans cette lourde étude d'impact je
n'avais plus la page l'apa chansons de
14 est très intéressante et 175 je vous
invite à tête reposée je pense ce
week-end à la lie car on voit tout à
fait l'inspiration de cette réforme la
page 174 en fait propre part du constat
que le système des retraites pèse trop
lourd en france 14 4% du pib' et on nous
explique qu'il fait 12,6 dans l'union
européenne
voilà et la page 75 c'est de nous dire
il faut donc qu'on descende
mais je vois que l'autriche et à 14,3
l'autriche ne me paraît pas un pays mal
gérés et a décidé de faire un effort en
faveur de ses anciens dont que la
fraternité parce que nous devons à nos
anciens aux futurs anciens c'est à dire
aux futurs retraités aux jeunes qui
travaillent dur